. Okay.
It's time for audience questions a little
earlier than normal in the week.
Normally we do these Friday, but we
are off Thursday and Friday for the Thanksgiving
holiday here in the United States.
So this being the last new show of the week,
we're going to do audience questions today.
Denise wrote in.
David, can you explain why isn't anybody talking
about the actual July 25 Ukraine phone call
that we don't even know how long it was.
How much does the call summary actually cover?
Apparently it was a 30 minute phone call and
we only got 10 minutes in the summary.
Yes, so this is, I've been repeating this
time and again and it's important to nice
that you understand it, but we need more people
to understand it.
Donald Trump teased the release of the transcript
of the July 25 phone call.
When we got that, it obviously wasn't a transcript.
It was a very partial transcripts transcript.
We can't even call it a summary because a
summary would in in sort of a narrative form
tell the story of everything that was said
in the phone call.
All they did is take a couple pieces of the
transcript.
The call is known to have been a half hour
phone call.
I think you're being generous when you say
the transcript covers about 10 minutes.
It might only cover six, seven or eight minutes.
By my estimation, Donald Trump has continued
to say, I have released the transcript and
it was a perfect phone call.
And the most disgusting and disturbing thing
about this is if you look at, we have a call
up on our YouTube channel from last week's
show, it's called something like furious Trumpist
implode spectacularly.
You know, we came up with some interesting
title on YouTube, but one of the things that
this person said during their call to me when
they went from one allegation to another,
it didn't, it was just circular.
They eventually said, listen, we saw the whole
transcript and it's fine.
And I had to remind him, we didn't see the
whole transcript.
We saw what our six to eight minutes of the
transcript, it was a 30 minute phone call
and you have fallen for the completely fake
narrative that the transcript is out there.
So are we ever going to see the full transcript?
I don't know.
Uh, if we put more pressure on and talk about
it, are we going to see it?
I, I'm not sure.
We've put more pressure on seeing Trump's
tax returns.
And I guess we could say we're slightly closer
to maybe someday seeing some version of them,
but it hasn't really done much so far.
So you know, there, there is scandal fatigue.
There are also so many different elements
to this thing.
There is, you've got the Devin newness, uh,
as a co-conspirator, uh, traveling to Vienna
to meet with Victor Shoken on taxpayer dollars.
You've got Donald Trump blurting out on Fox
and friends over the weekend that, Oh yeah,
actually, uh, I did ask them to do, to look
into this and why should we be giving them
hundreds of millions of dollars anyway, linking
for the first time, the quote investigation
and the money.
My point is there's so many elements of this
that it can be hard to get refocused on any
one thing even when we've obviously been lied
to.
And of course we've been lied to about the
transcript.
We don't have the transcript.
We have some paragraphs that have been pulled
from the transcript.
Even within the paragraphs there are ellipses
which are suspicious.
The white house has claimed nothing substantive
has been removed there.
Do we believe it?
Why would we, they lie all the damn time.
So I don't know the full scope of what's in
that transcript.
I remember Trump thinks the transcript vindicates
him.
It only is about a third at most of the call
and it's incriminating.
So just imagine if they calculated this might
help them or might not damage them.
Just imagine what the full transcript would
do.
I'm glad you're thinking about it, Denise.
I don't know what else we can do to try and
get that full transcript, but all we can do,
all I can do is to continue to repeat.
We've not seen the full transcript.
We should see the full transcript.
What they released is not a transcript.
Don't allow Trump to keep calling it that.
That's all we can do.
And maybe someday, even if it's a as evidence
in some kind of future proceeding, we may
be, we'll get to see that full call.